so a good consultant is doing well what
he or she is being told so you might sit
together with a project lead the Project
Lead provides you a data set and the
Project Lead asks you to conduct an
analysis based on this data set so good
consultant would do exactly that would
prepare a clean and nice analysis would
crunch the numbers but the great
consultant would go one step further the
great consultant in the middle of the
analysis might realize that the actual
question at hand cannot really be
answered by these numbers that are
included in the data set the great
consultant would go out potentially talk
to another client get this data that
would actually be needed then integrate
it in the analysis and then just prepare
the good final res